bonsoir mohammed moussaoui merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
les trois fédérations musulmanes déplore
l'absence de consensus celles qui n'ont
pas signé un ce texte déplore un manque
de consensus autour de ce texte qui je
cite est de nature à fragiliser les
liens entre les liens de confiance entre
les musulmans de france est la nation
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
l'islam de france c'est impossible islam
de france ne peut pas être laïque coûté
france il se construit depuis des années
avec la création de ces institutions de
ces mosquées de ses institutions au
niveau local puis au niveau national
cette étape celle de la charte et la
création de conseil national des imams
fait partie de ces de cette construction
qui s'inscrit dans le temps
l'impossibilité de construire cet islam
de france n'est pas tout à fait je pense
le terme à m à cette difficulté que nous
rencontrons ces derniers jours en effet
le texte de la charte dont vous avez
vous avoue que vous avez évoquées a été
validé à 90 voire 4 95% de son contenu à
l'unanimité compris les trois
fédérations qui n'ont pas signé
il reste 5 à 10% qui portent surtout sur
des formulations et et des nuances de
certains articles et non pas sur les
grands principes qui ont été inscrits
dans cette charte
de ce point de vue je peux dire c'est
une avancée significative importante
il reste que les trois fédérations ont
demandé un temps de réflexion pour voir
s'ils peuvent paraphé également le texte
je dois dire est que de réflexions de
combien de temps parce qu'on l'a dit il
ya un ultimatum
qui avait été lancée par l'elysée donc
ça c'est d'ici ce week-end d'ici lundi
comment convaincre ses fédérations
réticente sur quoi vous portez les
négociations comment réussir à tous se
mettre d'accord d'ici lundi
je ne pense pas qu'ils soient qui y est
nous dit maintenant quelconque à l'égard
de ces fédérations à l'égard du conseil
français du culte musulman je pense que
le dialogue que nous poursuivons avec le
président de la république que nous
remercions d'ailleurs pour l'intérêt
qu'il porte à ce dossier important je
pense que depuis son discours à mulhouse
bio le bureau et puis les rencontres
qu'il a eues avec le président avec le
conseil français du culte musulman
il montre bien qu'il a à l'intérêt très
particulier à ce dossier et souhaite que
le culte musulman soit organisée qui
soit à la hauteur des défis qu'ils
rencontrent
maintenant je pense que les trois
fédérations comme je le disais avait
déjà validé le 17 janvier je dois le
préciser
ils ont accepté que la proposition qui a
été présenté au présent unique soit une
proposition de consensus
il reste que les sectes 10% sur lesquels
ils ne peuvent pas mettre leur paraphe
mais à cette a7 je dirais à 7 e à cette
difficulté
j'ai toujours dit que huit fédérations
lorsqu'ils vont écrire un texte qui est
une coproduction forcément l'unanimité à
100 % sur chaque phrase
et puis impossible et je pense que le
compromis que nous avons tous les est un
très bon compromis
mais le fait qu'il manque sa signature à
ce que vous le regrettez est ce que ça
veut dire que le cfcm appareil à diviser
je l'enverrai évidemment que les trois
fédérations n'est pas signé le lundi
dernier
mais il reste on encore le temps pour
qu'il le fasse d'autant plus je dois
rappeler que le plus important pour nous
c'est les documents fondateurs du
conseil national 10e
celui là il a été ratifié par les huit
fédérations à l'unanimité déjà du pilot
le 10 novembre dernier
donc nous avons déjà réalisé une
contrepartie du travail qui devons-nous
et je pense que la mise en place du
conseil national estime axa devrait être
notre objectif premier
vous n'avez pas répondu à ma question
sur
division est ce qu'il ya une division au
sein du cfcm parce que les signatures ne
sont pas toutes présentes et est ce que
cette division si elles existent peuvent
mettre à mal le fragile édifice du
fameux islam de france voulue par
emmanuel macron civile et je fais la
différence entre le fait de ne pas
parapher un texte et avoir discuté et à
accepter 90 à 95 au sort de ce texte
nous sommes là devant une difficulté
effectivement jour où la corde mais il
n'est pas de nature à mettre en cause la
cohésion au sein du conseil ainsi du
culte musulman ça toujours été notre on
a eu des épisodes de cette nature dont
le passé il ya quelques jours et encore
la grande mosquée de paris le 28
décembre avait dit qu'elles ne
poursuivraient pas les travaux sur la
charte est sûre le conseil national
estime anne elle avait même dit que
c'était est irrévocable pourtant
aujourd'hui elle est autour de la table
parmi les principaux points en litige on
peut revenir là-dessus remet à la
définition des ingérences étrangères et
la définition précise de l'islam
politique
quand on regarde la composition du cfcm
le conseil français du culte musulman
que vous présidez on note la présence
d'une fédération turque qui refusent
d'ailleurs de signer la charte
si c'est le statu quo au d'ici la
semaine prochaine même si vous avez dit
il n'y a pas de a pas d'ultimatum
emmanuel m'apprend avait quand même
donné une quinzaine de jours il ya dix
jours si c'est toujours un statut secoué
le statu quo est ce qu'on pourra dire
que le cfcm n est pas représentatif
totalement des musulmans de france
le conseil français du culte en mai le
conseil par dans le nez n'est pas
représentatif des musulmans de france
ils représentatifs du culte musulman
c'est l'interlocuteur des pouvoirs
publics sur les question cultuelles ne
prétendons pas représenter les musulmans
en tant que citoyens ils ont leurs
représentants de la nation mais je pense
que le fait qu'il y ait une fédération
qui souhaiteraient rester à l'extérieur
on ne signant pas cette chape mais
acceptant de travailler avec le conseil
français du culte musulman sur la mise
en place du conseil national des imams
et accepter que ce conseil national 10e
puis sa grille et lci mal et je pense
que ça peut être un une situation de
d'intermédiaire le temps que la
fédération regarde avec ses instances et
et décider in fine et de signer le
document
je rappelle également que ce document il
va être soumis à toutes nos instances
régionales ce qu'on appelle le conseil
régional du culte musulman à nos
mosquées et les imams et les retours qui
seront faits par ces acteurs locaux et
permettront de d'améliorer le texte de
la charte donc le chat n'est pas
lui-même figé dans le temps il sera
amélioré par les retours et les retours
d'expérience que nous avons recueillies
auprès de nos acteurs locaux et je pense
que de ce point de vue une fédération
qui resterait peut-être qu'ils
mettraient des amendements en attendant
que tous ces retours soient soient
recueillies peut être une solution
également merci à mohammed moussaoui
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes le président du
conseil français du culte musulman